[Music]
tell us one Kardashian beauty secret oh
my god I have all of them Kim
Kardashian's right-hand man makeup
artist Mario dead Ivana Vic spills the
famous family's hottest beauty tip it
would have to be the under-eye technique
that they're all known for which is
basically like Kim's conceal baked right
in you know it's that like the layering
of the concealer and then the baking
powder and the brightening powder over
it it just gives them that sort of light
under eye that they really love how do
you keep from being creepy under the
eyes it's all about the blending if you
have too if you have too many lines or
wrinkles you don't want to do that much
you can do in a lighter way but it's all
about the blending if you blend the
initial concealer really really well and
you go with the light hand with the
loose powder you're good from the moment
he did my makeup I just felt like myself
I can't explain it I just was like like
I'm obsessed with you so you've got the
Masterclass yes
you have k'kaw Beauty collaboration
which is phenomenal thank you and you've
done something with anastacio Beverly
Hills yes when is makeup by Mario coming
out with his own collection oh good
question
that is my ultimate goal honestly I feel
like the past 18 years of my career have
been sort of the practice and the
stepping stone for that I can't tell you
when but you know that I've been working
very hard on on that so it will come in
the future how do you balance your work
life your jet-setting with Kim all the
time
and time for you it's it's it's hard I
mean you have a lot of sacrifices with
this with this job in this career but
I'm always I just remain kind of
grateful you know I try not to take
anything for granted
as far as battling to get I'm really bad
at that I'm not the best person to ask
about that because I kind of don't
balance it I'm just all about work right
now and focused and achieving my goals
and the type of person that has a hard
time saying no to somebody so I'm not
the best person but I did book a
vacation this year for ten days yes in
August and I'm so extremely excited
about that
et spoke with the makeup master at
beautycon LA where he dished on the
possibility of glam masters season to
you think of the glaad master they
really can do beautiful makeup like no
other you want glamorous beautiful I
haven't heard much about it but I think
I think it's definitely bigger and
better I mean it only gets better
everything feel like every show the
first season it's like kind of you know
the lot of learning and I think a lot of
people that saw the grand prize which is
massive a collab with Kim you know so I
could only imagine like the millions of
people that were applying for season two
[Music]